now I want to ask you Isaac something
you took a lot of anger a lot of people
on Twitter blamed you for ho doors death
and that's why I sat the two of you
together
I'd like I wanted a really awkward
conversation how did you feel about that
Twitter they got they got mad they were
sorry that's loco yeah I woke up to a
torn of few brands that way you're not
welcome here please all the why all the
f-bombs you want oh did you feel
Christian how did you okay how did you
interpret it did you interpret it that
it was his fault well any bitterness
towards bran at all if you're talking to
me or Hodor it's two different things
I'm apparently better towards them but
Hodor
I don't think who blames you
[Applause]